et ça les bienvenus dans cette deuxième
vidéo la virtual ou justin a toutefois
de baisser
elle serait long hyper-v regardez c'est
fini son camp moment je vais aller c'est
acer faire tu vas à la salle baudelaire
et explique aux gens il aura beaucoup
c'est tout en interne c'est beau ce sera
acharnée impressionnant jamais personne
faisant une pause est ce que je peux
faire mon intro à l'économat gauche
souvenez vous on s'était rendu dans un
monde parallèle où plutôt un fictif dans
un casque verdon avec qui fait des ouf
c'était génial
personne ne m'avait écouté mais c'est
vrai mais non il ya alors eu raison
parce quand j'ai vu le montage effet
c'est un truc de ouf quand on écoute pas
mais ben laden dans le placard [ __ ] on
peut mettre le casque
aujourd'hui on est de retour pourquoi
parce que la mission devient 2 sur wii
apparemment la difficulté par rapport à
la première mission c'est à dire qu'on
va devoir vraiment faire travailler nos
méninges et on va devoir et peut-être à
tous égards vraiment je vous jure la
dernière fois elle est excellente et 11g
mais quand d'écouté pas d'atouts du coup
pendant cette vidéo peut dire deux
choses oui on essaie de ne pas se
marcher dessus sept foyers et
deuxièmement si j'ai mis un bonnet c'est
pas pour contrer maquin lui sinon les
amis je préside un petit truc
aujourd'hui on veut pas vous spoiler
toute la mission lorsqu'ils gâcherait le
plaisir des gens si vous veniez ici
faire l'expérience je rappel vous pouvez
faire virtuellement de vous si vous
voulez vous êtes venus alors vous en
faites pas ça va y aura comme un fil
rouge dans la vidéo bien évidemment on
va finir on va réussir à s'enfuir en
rappel c'est une escale ken entre le but
c'est de sentir ta gueule qui excuse moi
parce que parmalat et les yeux des gens
les amis ça fait plaisir je vous
rappelle qu'on est chronométré on n'a
pas tout le temps comme moi ont guéri un
truc qui arrive là y'a un truc arrive à
sam écrasé les gars vraiment non c'est
bon
alors on a des poteaux devant nous et à
sa qualification d'affaires les mecs nos
atouts nos jours qu'est ce que je fais
comme dans cela regarde les fermer un
truc car c'est la macarena
ok les gars je suis chef d'equipe pour
m'équiper vous mettez pardon on a deux
conteneurs à gauche un droit parce que
tout le monde a un tableau devant lui
avec les mêmes petits boutons ouais
alors mon avis c'est comme au début il
va falloir juste trouver comment prendre
nos équipements il ya un code sur le
truc voyez tous les codes donc à mon
avis il faut juste chacun trouvé son
code qu'est ce que vous avez en bas de
votre écran tactile ben moi j'ai le
signe oméga noms sortent de l envers moi
j'ai un triangle
moi j'ai autre chose tu as quoi j'ai une
autre mais je pense que c'est quoi ok on
est très bon vous pouvez ouvrir sur le
côté les gars hors sol comme moi je veux
bien une banane violence hamas et les
gars c'est tellement frustrant d'avoir
un truc à boucles de pas pouvoir le
bouffer chers amis j'ai un écran avec
quatre symboles et quatre codes l'égail
à notre scène fille la regarde c'est
bien parce que personne ne m'a écouté
vous êtes incroyables pas bon alors je
t'écoute arrête de faire des crises
d'ego j'allais pas là pour ça brouille
et j'ai un ipad avec quatre cols et
quatre symboles et ballades mois de
symboles on egast appelez le comme c'est
un haut sens le tu coupes ambages 1,16
oui ça va chier ou donne moi ton symbole
toi n'at-on mois ci à l'inversé alors je
sais pas ok 76,46 mclaren bon symbole
c'est à une sorte de come to 41 68
mon accident je n'ai yes est important
de regarder a bien pu faire un ping pong
quinze jours moi je suis avec ma classe
ali c'est mon ami de mon côté j'ai pris
une pierre mort certains livres et la
clarté sont là m ici dans le même ton
père regarde les amis on a tué sa fille
un tutoriel en vraiment vous ne vous
écoutait pas ya une statuette du
cinquième élément
mais la tienne je suis persuadé qu'il
faut la rentrée tous les quatre en même
temps comme dans le cinquième élément
sans vous être juste que tu n'as faut
que jamais dans le bon sens juste raf
j'ai déjà insérés - ok du coup écoutez
le gard la mission n'est pas terminée il
ya un truc à part drôme au lieu de me
dire il ya un sens c'est comme quand tu
es à table ok j'ai un truc tu veux
prendre et que tu dis tu peux me donner
ça ce n'est pas un vrai une vraie phrase
mais juste le trou du jeu
oui écoutez besoin deux extraterrestres
envahissent les extraterrestres ont
envoyé des balises qui vers la galaxie
il nous espionnent depuis plusieurs
siècles ont la mémoire voici votre
mission vous devrez remonter le temps
beaucoup les bagues et des boucles
opération encore prouvé les télécharger
les données aliens qu'elles contiennent
et renvoyer ces de l'élève notre époque
bonne chance équipe oméga au caire dans
tous les gars de tout ça peut se trouver
un crime équipe
wasquehal n'a rien joli masque on doit
récolter l'énergie de la valise c'est ça
ouais regardez ma gueule génial ça à
l'époque des incas n'a tout va nous
raconter un peu cette époque alors les
incas font un très bon chocolat manière
on est chronométré mais là ça va pas
débattre sur mon terrain pour bien fait
comme ça tout le monde fait comme nathan
et je suis désolé je le comprends rien
je n'entends rien qu'est ce que tu as
fait naître j'ai trouvé une octobre dans
une des mains des statuts et ensuite je
les mises dans le feu pour l'allumer
graf
il a pas de feu note il faut que tu lui
donnes la tâche avec le feu que tu as
raconté
ecoutez-moi rapt en avant tu as une
fontaine là où tu es quand on regarde
bien sûr mais c'est blessant au caire
cas laissez moi dire laissez moi dire
y'a une boule qui est tombé en réaction
à ce qu'on a fait ah oui oui à l'arrêté
la boule dans le multivan league
il faut s'adresser à sa descente quand
tu mets la boule dedans ça me rappelle
tomb raider c'est une bonne situation
le salon est le soleil si aulas regardez
il ya un truc qui va se passer
peut-être qu'il ya magloire qui va
revenir regardez les gars c'est le
meilleur jeu de la vie les gars je veux
revenir et c'est que ma famille écouter
les coûteux et les trouver la sortie
mais c'était fou mais elles étaient trop
casse était pas tu vas bien toi voilà
comment commence à ce que tu a prévenu
sylvain pour l'accès my man is your day
lé pa là ne va pas c'est pas le mot à la
guerre vous dérange tout cela parce
qu'il n'a pas invité sylvain à
crémaillère au regard des regardez
regardez dit la détection quand j'ai mis
maintenant regarder ce qui se passe
[ __ ] fédéral est alors pour faire quoi
là à temps mais laisse moi là bas toi
mais arrêtez ont dû la fermer
voilà téléchargement moi je télécharge
la berge et le beau gosse on n'a cessé
de l'énergie qu'il faut récupérer
on est les premières boules d'énergie
alors il ne reste plus que trois bravo
les jeunes je comprends rien
attendez je n'ai pas de l'année si vous
prenez un temps pour regarder le paysage
qui est un brillant
oui c'est vrai que c'est magnifique la
différence entre le décor et la gueule
que vous avez est tellement dingue alors
je critique pas mon visage soit ça
commence à bien faire
comment ces jeunes femmes à toi je
demande mon avis je voulais pas te faire
mal pour de vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez à vos pieds il y à un câble je
pense qu'il faut tout ce qu'on vous dit
les capitiens au pied les gars d'accord
on peut pas les prendre
ne pas y manque des morceaux de câbles
est ce que quelqu'un peut nous dérouler
son câble passé qui lui sont pétés
quelqu'un qui a pété un câble ou quoi oh
lalalalalalalalala écoutez moi dans ce
tonneau à l'égard de la poutre faut
juste reliés mais c'est bien toi je
voulais la dire bah fallait être plus
rapide c'est tout vous renier les deux
câbles ok c'est bon pour tout le monde
qu'on dirait une énorme merde
ok les gars sait tout faire péter mais
les gars c'est pas bien trop longue à
regarder mais on est de train ok les
gars vous avez un sac vous avez un
chariot l'apprenez ce cadeau dans vous
pétez le cadenas avec la pioche moi
c'est déjà fait à plat est ce que tu
peux me passer la paire cheminots
souhaitent regarder écouter jamais vous
m'écoutez jamais écoutez moi je respecte
les animaux mais bonheur défonce les
aigles maison mais j'aime pas envie de
participer à cette tuerie menti
[Musique]
je vous rappelle que peut cacher un
autre
les bus de la côté normand vous pouvez
le prendre pour vers les caisses alors
atteint d'un pied de biche sur le train
et normand vous pouvez le prendre
ouais ben ouais les gars je vois trop le
pied de biche quand vous parlez trop
bien hâte à fabrice notre énorme non
plus il ya que moi qui ai un
pied-de-biche non moi aussi vas-y fais
péter le big boss fin du mois mais il va
se reformer regarde ensuite vous allez
avoir un marteau les amis vous tapez sur
le petit truc en moi qui se trouve sur
le train une fois que la planche et
péter vous pourrez tourner la roue ou
alors vous faites tourner là j'ai hâte
de voir ce plan où je tape nulle part je
voulais même plus sur le truc de temps
mais je me dis que maintenant c'était
pas possible mais à la youtube monnaie
bas pour vos os 4 millions en fait suce
moi c'est ça a joué les amibes à mon âge
et angoisse je suis seul dans l'espace
et vous ferons je suis dans un sas de
sécurité pareil - sas vous avez une
petite trappe que vous pouvez me david
où es-tu je suis une trappe les gardes
milieu moi il me faudrait une sorte de
croix à mettre dans ce truc
donc faudrait qu'on s'échange des formes
alors moi j'ai un cylindre qui ressemble
à une grosse style ouais je l'est aussi
pas à mon avis il faut le placer chez
les rouges les rentrées super actif
l'attend pas illégal est-ce qu'on peut
passer en second degré et juste qui fait
regarder mais c'est fou c'est fou voilà
son frère ça va encore mais attendez
attendez attendez attendez attendez
depuis le début vous voyez tous vous
voyez pas tout le monde s'en bat les
couilles mais je fasse
lucas qui s'y fait arrêter lucas ils
boudent les gars ça c'est pas du cam
cgpi
adobe ne boude pas sa vraie écoute moi
je vais prendre une salade césar à midi
et je te donnerai juste la sauce lucas
c'est toi qui me paye mon repas ce midi
bon bah alors dans ce cas je me lave les
mecs c'est toi qui a eu son bac avec
mention ici moi moi non assez bien
jusqu'à regardez regardez ravva faire un
truc voyage regardez bien ce qui se
passe quand on a grandi à votre longue
avec une mer de qualité et voilà david
skitt peuvent-elles être qui alla
l'ajustement soutiendrait biocarb écoute
moi j'ai besoin de ce que tu as en face
de toi ce coup là oui certes en face de
toi là j'ai réussi à mettre l'objet dans
la l'espèce de trappes mois ils vont
envoyer deux autres ils ont besoin qui
aura besoin de ses grilles nuque
enfin c'est ce que pense que c'est
raisonnable et ça avec les jeunes et
c'est pour nous tous bafta fait
franchement dix minutes que je vous dis
que deux films envoyés ces pièces et
aimé jacquet chier mais parce que on en
voit on t'envoie pas chier on envoie les
pièces actuellement au sénat mais les
deux ans et je pense mon truc va
s'ouvrir et j'aurais mieux voilà c'est
propre ça les gars j'ai peut-être des
orioles mais ces deux-là virtuel au réel
évidemment je fais c'est pour toi
bravo les gars ouest yves et moi
j'arrête de parler parce que j'ai peur
d'être trop brillant ici regardez moi
par ici ouais ouais là vous avez des des
trucs à monter mettez tout sur le vert
ah oui tu as raison [ __ ] bien oui moi
j'en laisse un rouge dans banon du coup
ça va bloquer tout le monde pas moins la
lecture sur le vert moi j'ai commis un
an j'ai tout misé sur le rouge
c'est génial
la vue de ce mois
waouh la vie est plus nul que ce jeu moi
l'espace le bonheur regardez j'ai un
casque de cosmonaute et parole ils vont
pouvoir les enlever ce pas la garde et
coucou c'est nous excusez moi comme je
suis le plus poète et le plus mature et
contemplatif observer ce qui se passe
j'aimerais prendre un moment donc on
s'allonge tous et qu'on mettait un petit
peu oui allez est-ce qu'on peut chanter
un peu plus près des étoiles surtout
sans moi tout de suite tu es moi tu es
moi les amis ce moment est magnifique et
j'aimerais vous dire à quel point c'est
un plaisir de tourner avec vous depuis
ces deux années vous êtes mon rayon de
soleil grave tu peux venir vers moi
juste la vie de fer restant allongée
j'aimerais qu'on s'allongeant sans toi
et moi je t'aime bien merci
[Musique]
il a visité sa combinaison j'ai vu
quelqu'un du sopalin peau qu'est ce qui
fait qu elle ne regardera nous a laissé
des caisses les mecs vous avez des
arbres c'est parti at on dit
comment on fait pour mettre les
recharges dedans comme en valais
recharges
j'arrive pas à notre la rochelle alors
vous les mettez en couleurs avant tout
ouais je prenais le génome de malades
mais je n'arrive pas à mettre ma carte
ou
les gars ont achoppé avec les recettes
j'ai vraiment été inutiles pendant cette
partie qui vous attend sur scherwiller 2
500 mm que vous avez collecté ont permis
à nos ingénieurs en sorte qu'on espère
assez puissante pour détruire novembre
on va se débrouiller de l'année où deux
forts c'est space x
oh là là voilà j'ai la boule j'ai la
boule qu'est-ce que celle de maboule
mettez vos boules dans les drom et t
mobile dans les dom à fall a lancé c'est
bon je vais lancer sa vache second au
québec et six pack moyens au [ __ ]
oh les gars je côtoie le droit ah ouais
quand même
comment t'as fait ça et là vous vous
laissiez dans le cube s'arrête un bordel
quand vous prenez la volée que vous
l'avancé le drone avance quand vous
lever la boule ronde se lève et ses faux
pas les faire les gars là j'ai perdu
c'est fini la la la la
ça c'est une note sans réserve en plâtre
aux cas sur la plateforme qui est en
face de toi là-bas dans deux villes où
les gars quand vous avez perdu votre
route
les gars napo mais nos drones ces shows
ils ont perdu leur drôle et de gros cons
mcphail carlo ou détruit l'humanité
souscrivez à un abonnement et en libye
où il faut aller les amener la barre
regarder rien les chantres années à les
regarder n'a pas bien joué et bien joué
dans la basilique et lui la gueule
au 9 jan
l'ias la flotte aliens et détruit la vie
rien fera le rêve c'est comme la foire
du trône mais au mieux aux socialistes
pas venir c'est une expérience
incroyable et surtout vous ressortez
avec cette tête et ça mon gars ça fait
des très belles photos un statut jamais
parti en vacances ensemble on est
dégoûtés le constat qui nous laisse pas
manquer cette expérience quand même se
souvenir de tout ce que ça mais moi
c'est dans le jeu tu sais dans le jeu
que ça m'a fait ça mes amis c'est la fin
de cette vidéo n'était pas allez
messieurs vous a plu merci d'avoir
regardé n'hésitez pas à vivre
l'expérience en fait franchement ces
chants de mer n'est pas payé pour faire
cette vidéo quoi mais c'est juste trouve
ça trop bien trop innovant c'est génial
en attendant abonnés mois la chaîne de
tous ces gens y compris la sienne sur
instagram
mais ça va regarder au revoir et encore
merci à vous joseph viola fin de
l'expérience en vrai
[Musique]